One way to think about a delegate
is to imagine that each
key difference one sees across
views of the same class,
corresponds to a question that
the view could ask of its delegate.
For example, what should I do
with these new characters?
How should I respond when
the return button is clicked?
What should happen when editing begins?
in other words,
the view needs some other class to
decide what to do with user input.
So, what kind of object can
answer these questions?
The view's delegate is usually, but not
strictly, going to be a control object.
It makes sense for control objects
to answer the view's questions,
because control objects are designed
to perform tasks like passing
user input to a data model.
The key to the delegate pattern, is that
the view establishes the questions that
it needs answered and
encodes them in a protocol.
A protocol is a list of methods
that a delegate must implement.
Any object that fulfills
the protocol can become a delegate.